[Music]
[Laughter]
this show is brought to you by cash shot
as you know cash up is the simplest way
to send and save money and now it's the
simplest way to try and grow your money
with cash app investing I use cash app
to pay all my friends back I use cash
app to pay if somebody covers some four
bills or dinner or something it's real
quick and it's really easy to use you
know and that's also the app you use if
you got no dents and I pay one fire and
in Ivan gets rid of his entire salary
using a cash app to be brutally honest
with you am I gonna tell you what I
invested in no we're gonna have much no
do I already have a money guy to handle
all this for me yeah brokerage services
are provided by cash up investing a
subsidiary of square and member s IPC
and as always when you sign up for cash
app and use the promo code Congrats not
only will you instantly receive $10 but
cash out will also now donate ten
dollars to The Trevor Project an amazing
organization that provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services for LGBTQ youth across America
download cash up from app store from the
App Store or Google Play Store today
[Music]
one city at a time so Chicago Illinois
I'm here your boys here December 30th
mm-hmm got a sold-out show
and then tomorrow December 31st December
30th right tomorrow does number 31st
Chicago Illinois got two shows some few
few tickets left to join New Year's Eve
join me on New Year's Eve to bring in
the new year so if you're in Chicago
come see a boy and raise a glass raise a
glass with me in Chicago Illinois
ah now when I say Chicago does it remind
me does it always make do I always want
to always think about Chicago do I was
thinking about going Chicago even though
it's Chicago yeah I do and every time I
do that do I then think about an old
movie that I used to see when a guy was
talking [ __ ] these two guys were talking
[ __ ] and I think it was only the strong
and the guy who was a bad guy talking
like this and he was like and the guy
was like asking him questions and then
he and then the line was your inner the
interviews over
and he says job interviews over my
friend
job interview he says job interviews
over my friend and you know the director
was like okay all right he's not that's
the probably best we're gonna get God
what was that was that only the strong
was that bad I no way but I no way about
and I remember that movie only the
strong part on the way para no way about
Ana la ran away to to to capoeira
it's a rule that's what they would do
here we go this is so long let's see how
close I am to it okay
Diggle part of the way but I don't weigh
about Ana to to to couple it out oh okay
listener
Wow
they don't give a [ __ ] what they're
saying if they do it they say plot on
that way whenever they want
[Music]
once we got [ __ ] the flag for this
playing this okay and then you're like
okay well so this is pretty much just
this song it doesn't really have a
bridge or anything okay
[Music]
alpharetta you know just fight um flashy
fighting but i knowwe pat on away about
Anna what is the [ __ ] your interview
let's see if we have this you're doing
interviews over my friend no only the
strong no I don't remember what was that
[ __ ] God look up the guys on because
I'll recognize that the people-to-people
but while we're doing that I got a text
from my [ __ ] [ __ ] friend Brian
Council I'm playing a dick Chicago I'm
playing three shows three more shows in
Chicago Chicago theater not him that guy
that's him yeah see if you could find to
be interviews over my friend
so the Bryant cell Bryan Callen is
playing the Wilbur in Boston now if you
are in Boston and you're Archer baby and
you're going to see Brian where your
[ __ ] crystally emerge you know those
are the rules
and try to be in the front row if you
can't that's fine
but this is the [ __ ] text I get did I
get a video from this [ __ ]
Brian count today this is what he says
now is it not conversation yesterday
about the people are making fun of my
hair of this [ __ ] and they were
saying that the debate was with Johnny
Depp be Johnny Depp if he had my hair
you know what would his career looked
like probably be on TV somewhere or
whatever they were saying no in his hair
a lot of his you think of Johnny Depp
you think of that long black hair
that's stringy kind of bad boy hair and
bad boy hair 5010 you know it still
dresses like a pirate I'm not comparing
you to Johnny Depp at all but I had this
too I mean I am along like them I had
this crazy dream that you
cut your hair and everything dried up
you know somebody was like did his
[ __ ] career you know I was like no
you know and there's such a crazy dream
don't cut your hair do you think you're
a comedy Samson do you do you think that
you're a comedy Samson look if Delilah
crawled into your tent snip snip snip
the terrifying sound to you
I'm happy holidays buddy I love you I
miss you come on do the Wilbur sold out
some seeds up in the upper balcony some
seats up in the upper balcony yeah so to
go see him but if you go see him
make sure to absolutely wear the merch
okay and get those seats in Opera Ballet
balcony is this hit you don't know what
if this is it or not these are just all
the scenes yeah job interview is over my
friend yeah I think it's schoolyard
fight scene dude why don't you let the
kid go I just told you my business look
at the badass [ __ ] kid go what's up with
a tease when I'm on this isn't it but
Wow of course this guy's in it
[Music]
lips oh so 80s do sit 80s
this isn't it but Wow mm-hmm who's the
guy that says you'll be torito's over my
friend oh here oh here too late but this
is the trailer only the strongest of the
most 80s movie over like here's a
trailer can we play a trailer
here's a trailer only the strong Wow
[Music]
slam the seeds of miles where no
discipline
you must think I'm playing that's the
guy that's the guy oh wow and you look
up - Wow the [ __ ] sound effect like
throwing a loaf of bread on a [ __ ]
piece of wood you had a job you're
supposed to do last night each dish is
man alive there's no way in hell that
that guy didn't [ __ ] die of HIV for
real look at him there is no way he
looks so much like a guy that would
[ __ ] die of HIV it's unbelievable you
had a job you're supposed to do last
night fish one of their own was crazy
enough to take them on
Oh kids I said turn it up Wow so many uh
[Music]
that's true that's inaudible Centro I
grew shot is good trotty there's one of
these kids bodies is so as serife that
can't even believe it how much is like
Don Cheadle in this for [ __ ] their
change in his small parts in that car
the sexiest man of all time definitely
died of HIV the only guy who got HIV
from a woman like that was straight male
the only man in the history of humanity
that had sex that he had sex of so many
girls that he legitimately got it from a
woman doctors like I've never seen
anything like it does he have scrapes on
your dick and he's like no I don't ever
have straight scripts on my dick and
he's like well how did you get it I
don't understand I I was having sex with
a girl like [ __ ] in her side of her and I
get the AIDS how does it happen like
you're just that goddamn sexy
changing these were the twelve worst
kids at Lincoln the absolute ultimate
heat look at what he's done with him I'm
judging there were gonna have to see em
again
[Applause]
Wow they're taking the challenge of
their lives and they're turning it into
a triumph of the lifetime one way or
another do getting in that car here find
out who that got what that guy's name is
and then we'll look up the scene and
only the strong with that I can't
believe I remember that that's an only
the strong I saw that when I was seven
and me and my brother were like job
interviews over
wow dude when we were another Jew
getting in that car wow you could find
that scene come on dude it's the part
where he's talking to the other guy and
he's [ __ ] and they're trying to turn
like the guy bad guy so if you can't one
fire so wait but but wait let's look up
that guy actually let's see what he's
doing now what do you think that guy
does now I [ __ ] love doing this man
what who got what are they doing now
dude you know what I want I'll [ __ ] that
bro let's remake only be strong and I'm
gonna be that guy job interview is over
my friend that guy I need I need to play
see that's what sucks bro now only like
really specific actors like if you're
gonna get a guy to play that role like
remember when Al Pacino played a [ __ ]
Tony Montana like that would never
happen now this is a [ __ ] white guy
playing this guy from wherever the [ __ ]
Tony Montana's from they wouldn't it
would never who's this guy Wow look at
this guy this is the sexiest guy ever I
I have to start dressing like this I
told Steve Trevino and Eric Griffin once
when I got fit when I got real [ __ ]
famous I'm dressing a lot differently
and I've told you guys this and I stand
by it
and I finally got some [ __ ] honey and
pants that are the same and they're all
a floral design and I look [ __ ] boss
dude you can't
from me I got to the level of Fame where
now I can wear a [ __ ] hoodie and
sweat and have them both be the same
floral-print are you serious
it's a can now I don't and I got those
the other day and I showed up at the
Comedy Store and people are like wow
okay bro and I was like did you think I
was lying back then did you think I was
lying back then I'm definitely at the
[ __ ] point of Fame to where I can do
that at least now when I level up when
army of the Dead comes out it's gonna be
another step closer to the [ __ ] two
wearing what this guy wears just a
[ __ ] straight-up leather vest with
nothing underneath nothing underneath
and I'm gonna wear that and if you don't
think I am you're [ __ ] you don't know
me okay
leather pants awesome belt buckle and
leather vest period that's it
when army the Dead comes out or if I get
like some sort of movie oh god forbid
I'm I'm I'm ever in a franchise god
forbid I'm ever in a franchise I'm only
wearing a shirt and that's it no pant
just a long shirt and the shirts gonna
have like you know dead that guy wearing
that on it the job interview guy you get
the link of the guy yeah I sent I texted
it to you on congratulations text that's
the guy I mean that guy is I mean look
at the at the end of the [ __ ] trailer
it says la create toward their blood
sport oh they full contact and they all
did all that sure who is that guy
does it say Paco Wow
Paco Christian Prieto three names sexy
couldn't Antonio Banderas would see this
guy and he would be like he would
literally kneel down and be like i
acquiesce you are the sexiest man
everything until Panera says it's like
this he goes up that's good acting when
you're Spanish for real what is he is he
Spanish or my racist he's Mexican okay
calm racist crisis
um everything he says it's like this he
does oh my god have you ever see the
movie assassins with my friend Sylvester
Stallone yeah and Antonio Banderas dude
what is this guy in what is his name
Paco Christian Brito got it right here
Silverio plays Silverio and everything
is so sex about this guy can't even
believe it he's in Lionheart with
jean-claude Van Damme Street law
champions that came out in 1997 what's
he been in recently nothing dude what
does he do now damn I want to know what
did I want to hang out with this guy
jean-claude van Damme Lionheart let's
skip the Lionheart wait we got to
[ __ ] find out what we got to find out
this scene we have to see this job
interviews oh you have to hear this job
interviews over
and that's it and that's final you know
and that's [ __ ] final let's go to
youtube and find this I'm gonna find it
I'm gonna find it for you babies I do
the work for your babies you understand
I look stuff up I do research I don't
just [ __ ] here we go what's it called
only the strong Wow oh here it is I
think this is it wow he's wearing the
most awesome [ __ ] interview I wonder if
I just say I don't know they're here god
damn it it was scene scene scene scene
here we go scene scene only this song
that music you know parking-lot scene
school here we go combat only this
strong only death strong yeah it's not
gonna where we can't find it
oh here it is here it is supposed to
last night okay
let me let me let me just preface this
my brother night saw this 20 years ago I
don't know if he actually says job
interviews over but that's how it
morphed into our [ __ ] brain over the
years
if he says job interviews over I might
stop this podcast out of sheer joy the
turrets are back from the playground oh
my god dude whoa oh my god you know what
I hope like here's the deal that guy
obviously English is in his first
language and I'm not one of those guys
it's like oh you know good so dumb he
doesn't know how to how about the fact
that he knows how to speak more than one
language I don't like when people are
like oh you [ __ ] speak English bro
the guy is smarter than you he's smarter
than me he knows more languages than I
do
I barely know Aang okay so this guy
comes in and does that but bro I wanna
be I gotta [ __ ] get to the point
where I'm doing movies in either Mexico
or whatever the [ __ ] this guy's from and
I have that dope of an accent on the
other end do you understand like I'm
just like agua en de su mejor
ahahahahahaha guac ain't they assume a
whole horde de mundo yeah and they're
like this and the people from Mexico
they're going like instead of going
they're going I see or whatever I mean
dude do you understand if I was
directing this movie when that guy did
that I would look to the next two people
next me I'd be like we got it we need to
just cut after this scene I would be
going yes [ __ ] yes the children's are
back from the playground so dope dude
wearing a purple shirt with the buttons
open and the collar out and it's too big
look at this
the chooser survival displayed amazing
now the for the people listening do you
want to guess if his hair is so long in
a ponytail and the top is short or do
you not want to guess cuz you know dude
[ __ ] other guy standing next to him to
his left to the right and screen looks
like he's there for an audition
supposed to last night good family in
pocket and I respect you man but now
does the guy he's talking to have the
same hair yes you piece of [ __ ]
studio musician so [ __ ] hard rock
can't was beforehand he was like I'm
going to AG this honestly the best you
ever seen acting and he added little
piece of [ __ ] and the directors like
okay I feel it I feel you had a job you
were supposed to do last night - you
piece of [ __ ] Wow Silverio
your family is how I talk during sex - I
respect you man but I'm not your slave
here we go smeii Wow
adlet really hit him hey we got a little
rebellion going on here you starting to
talk that kind of [ __ ] to your brother
to it Kali Mia uh-huh hey no brother
minor more and he show it on all me
that's what you Jamaica so weak like if
I could say man didn't even act it
thinks that in real life and first of
all the guy comes out of the bus the
lead of the movie comes out of the bus
what was he doing for [ __ ] three
minutes it's literally right there what
was he doing jerking off like a man I
really want to [ __ ] save these guys
but I gotta bust a nut first do little
piece of [ __ ] and he's just like what
was he doing playing [ __ ] Nintendo
switch get out there I mean these guys
the way they're dressed dude they're all
dressed for real I mean this guy what's
this guy's name
Sergio Kato what the [ __ ] guy's name
is like it does not sound the dragon is
the other guy anyway whoever this guy is
always dresses like he's going to Lamaze
class starts in about five minutes
the Sun - I sure know you're the one who
started this [ __ ] Wow
oh well a girl pops out of the bus and
then also he was [ __ ] the girl cuz
that's the only excuse why it took him
so long to get out there took him in and
a half she pops her head out well scan
the bus Diana tell you what Santa you
take my cut see
I'll take her she better leave now
see you got mad without your cousin my
cousin in case you didn't know it's not
a student of this school anymore it's
not working for me full-time that is
cause this is decision or was it yours
you know what Santa here we go I'm
trying to be a nice guy
Wow here's I mean he just punched his
cousin it's a bad writing
I'm trait to be a nice guy but you know
what he's not going to this class
anymore dish I mean so much angry one
scene from jump dude I love when scenes
don't go from A to B I love when they
start at B and end that be when it's
like everyone's mad immediately it's
like that [ __ ] scene when when in the
movies where they still do it in movies
where like the the cop doesn't like the
new cop for no goddamn reason like I
don't know about this guy but I don't
like him and you're like why dude like
there's I'm trying to be a nice guy
Wow but now you're really trying to piss
me off a lot of people in this town will
tell you
you see me oh oh it's not a smart thing
to do yeah it kind of didn't give us any
like real starting point though you know
you were pissed off you really started
to piss me off
he says that one second oh here it is
more logical see me - it's gonna be - oh
[ __ ] what's that story they're circling
around oh my girl
so where's you can point on my history
Wow
if he wants to discover my territory
he's got to give me something you think
she's gonna think you better leave
I never all right dude I swear to God if
I don't find this goddamn pig
well it's got really all right dude I
didn't find it sorry I felt the babies
it's okay
I'll find it for next one episode
because I can't spend time looking at
this but do it wow that's amazing
uh I got a I got a B I gotta be doing
that
I gotta be doing those kinds of movies I
got it [ __ ] be doing those kinds of
movies man all right should I do an ad
yeah I guess so
Roman most guys have tried different
ways to last longer but saying the
Pledge of Allegiance in your head or
counting backwards from 10 doesn't
always work or thinking about your
friends sweaty palms
my friend has sweaty palms sometimes I
think about his sweaty palms or Calvin
and Hobbes the folks at Roman a men's
health company are changing the game
with Roman swipes the secret to
longer-lasting sex Roman swipes are
clinically proven to last longer they
help last longer in bed they're
effective easy to use and fast-acting
but don't require a prescription so
there you go don't have to go to the
doctor to get it Roman can ship swipes
to you in discreet unmarked packaging
and each swipes packet is small enough
to hide in your wallet for whenever you
need it so you can be kind of sly about
it if you're like things are going well
with the chick swipes are great and they
will not transfer to your partner so you
can last longer without worrying they're
super easy to use just take swipes out
of the packet swipe it on let it dry and
you're good to go
that's it get $10 off your first order
of swipes and free 2-day shipping at get
Roman comm slash babies that's get Roman
comm slash babies $10 off and for $10
off and free two-day shipping get Roman
comm slash babies congratulations is
brought to you by cash app the official
app of the log cabin dude I love ATS
week I wonder if it's about me being
from the 80s in it being nostalgic like
or my kids gonna like watching this [ __ ]
they're probably like dad I don't want
to watch another Sergio kado movie or
whatever the [ __ ] what's his that's the
guy from Iron Chef by the way what's his
name again
chef dude that is that that's a killer
gig to have
Mark Dacascos cask disgust Dacascos one
fire spelled it wrong cool dark asko's
do you want or maestro you gonna get it
wow that guy [ __ ] dude he [ __ ] hard
Antonio Banderas I don't know who's hot
who's hotter then that either of them
seen like when Antonio Banderas came and
did the [ __ ] desperado was that the
movie was that the movie did desperado
seen in assassin but there was nobody
was sexier than into the Banderas
honestly was the sexiest in Assassin's
and that's everybody knows that his hair
gelled like this with the [ __ ] pubes
coming out from the back like he had his
dick on the back of his head I need to
get a dick on the back of my head and
kind of kind of kind of uh what do you
call it the way with guns dude you
murdered to see where he closes the
laptop Oh God when he does when he does
okay I'm gonna reenact it on this video
here what I'm gonna do it he's here with
[Music]
Wow the choices he makes house it's slow
motion dude he goes like that this how
he does he goes like this wow that's
honestly [ __ ] you Hollywood for not
having him at least nominated for a
[ __ ] Golden Globe and assassins for
that scene dude closing Allah make you
don't understand making a choice that
specific is as good as [ __ ] King
speech iiiii it's as good as Colin Firth
dude Colin Firth and in sking speech and
Antonio Banderas when he closes the
laptop in Assassin's both exactly the
best kind of caliber acting I swear to
god Dean urdahl Lewis would look at that
if he was smart and be like wow no
honestly that's better than I was in the
[ __ ] human quilt or whatever the [ __ ]
that movie was dude when he [ __ ]
what is he doing with his hand and it's
slow motion when he [ __ ] opens his
mouth dude who directed this amazing bro
oh wow
dude you know Ben Darras is so good
because he is equal parts acting of the
most intense [ __ ] that you can possibly
do but also doesn't give a [ __ ] about it
that's the best acting you can do
especially in the [ __ ] he does like when
you have guns like where your [ __ ]
like okay [ __ ]
here we go here we go but then he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about he's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on you know what I mean dude it's
so dope he'll like he'll like they bust
into a door and his hair will come over
his face and he'll be like okay this is
it I meant that tonight but also it's
alright tonight it's alright to get
there I'm at the tonight but it's
alright we'll get there
that's it I'm an acting teacher now
babies I'm an acting teacher now and
that is the pinnacle of acting I made
that tonight but it's gonna be alright
to get there that's that's how you act
in everything you think that [ __ ]
King speech was an iiiii he wasn't
thinking that Antonio Banderas [ __ ] it
also helps to be good at acting when you
have [ __ ] hair that's long and
nicking like go in front of your face
when you're doing like crazy sweaty
scenes it's [ __ ] secretly good acting
wow man amazing he's my favorite actor
what was the [ __ ] jean-claude Van
Damme chunk lot of Fame damn dude Jan
cloud
the thing about jean-claude Van Damme is
he's four or five four foot eight
probably he's got to be he's gotta be 4
foot 8 o rata screamin your son of a
[ __ ] Hey
how are you
welcome to my party you're like who open
the door and then you look down over
here would you like to come in my wife
one of my wife's is making catch and
then and then and then she's like the
quiche is almost done John Claude Van
Damme and he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] for
that's a good thing [ __ ] make more
straighter we're done eating but I still
want you in the kitchen
did you understand do you guys want to
see who can fit into a fireplace do you
want to see out of any of us who can fit
into a fireplace
I bet it's me I have four and then other
people are like well that's not fair
you're four foot eight he just goes hey
get out [ __ ] [ __ ] wow dude died
dude that's a [ __ ] dude what is up with
you gotta be suited what the [ __ ] man
action heroes they don't have that
anymore that real specific I mean
Stallone was like that's so specific
that's why it was so good
junko VIN it was like gonna kick that
son of a [ __ ] by sunset Shaw board and
then Segal the director just like speak
ah and he was just like I do with my
hands you know when it Seagal was just
doing the [ __ ] like he's knitting a
[ __ ] sweater and he just I swear to
god one in some scenes he's just doing
like batting like a cat like this dude
Segal doesn't even know martial arts he
just made up that he knows martial arts
oh this is what Steven Seagal says about
Van Damme and other action stars Wow
since you've been here last four hard to
kill we've had a lot of action adventure
stars popping out of the woodwork do you
go watch the other guys would Jeff
Speakman or vana Dom you know do you
know Vaughn Dom oh no oh oh oh so mad
that he's bringing it up you heard him
oh look how mad you heard him wait wait
wait says no no no so confident has five
girls in his green room right now and
that's what he thought he literally
thought this is what he thought wouldn't
[ __ ] and Arsenio Hall as it Arsenio
Hall said do you know do you know Vaughn
DOM and Steven Seagal literally went
through this lightening quick as quick
as as does his [ __ ] Aikido he thought
okay well now now it's [ __ ] because
this interview isn't about me he's asked
about another action star and that's not
fair because this is about me okay I I'm
the [ __ ] I have four girls in my green
room all good and then cocked his head
and said no you know do you know Vaughn
Dom no that's what he thought what do
you think of his work as a martial
artist first oh boy you guys so he said
you would you just subject what a hater
dude what a hater shell arts world
before you were movie stars right I mean
he was like a champion somewhere and
right
I mean you well I mean I I just promised
all my mentors that I was gonna be a
good boy I think there's an opinion that
he was a champion anywhere I mean dude
imagine being that much of a piece of
[ __ ] I mean just be like yeah yeah he's
good he's good he does his [ __ ] thing
as movies kill whatever [ __ ] it
yeah and I mean you know I'm not being
caddy or anything I wish the guy all the
best
oh really but there are an awful lot of
people who say that that's not true
how about Jeff Speakman nice guy Wow
teacher you know in Park was a good
friend of mine and she seems like a real
good a real good guy this kid I've never
met him but he seems like a good kid
who's the most legitimate Hollywood
tough guy in your opinion you accept
that of course when you say tough guy do
you mean martial artists or just Tommy
I mean Stephen for real if he was on the
street and there was a situation you
wanted this Hollywood guide by your side
because he could defend him skinnier why
it's that hard to think of a legit one
can you think of like he can't even
consider it alright another guy should I
laugh in your face Michael Jai White can
I laugh in your face dude wow dude word
you know what we're learning in this
podcast today so many ways to [ __ ]
slam somebody before a goddamn fight I
mean looks like the children's are out
from the playground between that and
gonna laugh in your face right now oh
the [ __ ] shear [ __ ] suck of being
polite about being a [ __ ] is
unbelievable can I laugh in your face
right now oh I got a do that imagine
being in a relationship with [ __ ]
Steven Seagal hey can you take the trash
out and just him like this if
question for you where do you [ __ ]
get off this house this house that
you're in with 40 rooms who paid for it
well what do you mean I mean we both who
paid for it
well I just who paid for it well you did
do you think I've done enough work what
do you mean for do you think I've done
enough work yes Stephen I get what I get
where this is going sure I get it so why
would I take out the trash
why would I do more work in the house
that I that I did the work for to pay
for it
Jen clever and then pick it out okay
someone for bill can I laugh in your yes
vote song-chun Billy yes oh wow there's
more right should I laugh in your face
really yes votes on jean-claude Van
Damme can I laugh in your face oh wow
Chuck Norris I mean Chuck is in his
mid-70s press 76 years old okay
75 76 or something Wow interesting
thank you don't know I don't I've heard
that he's not you know so I mean I don't
really want to get into on film anyway
you know who's a tough guy why I think
Michael is a tough guy no do I think
he's a martial artist no try things on
clubs a tough guy on marshallers no why
not dude you know like why not
the ego on the guy that he can't even
speak on another guy that's good is
unbelievable
imagine if that's how it was in comedy
if somebody was just like yeah what do
you think of [ __ ] what do you think
of jo koy and I was just like can I
laugh at your face right now
can I laugh of your face right now ting
ting I don't think so okay what do you
think about [ __ ] Eric Griffin can I
love your [ __ ] face right now you see
this muscle on Showtime can 11 you
[ __ ] face right now Andrew Santino
Theo von ha
can I love you [ __ ] face right now
who do I think is a funny guy like just
on the street like what the [ __ ]
wow that's amazing it would be like me
squashing an ant dude Steven Seagal is
[ __ ] like 60 here like ghetto covered
in Frasure ate his girl's [ __ ] for real
because he couldn't [ __ ] it because it
wasn't tall enough careful now
I will just look up unzip your pants and
did her pussy's me he runs here's young
Van Damme in his youth I mean how could
you say Junko Vadim is not a [ __ ]
martial artist he literally can kiss his
knee standing up Wow how could you say
that that's so funny that somebody could
be that insecure that they can't even
give another guy a compliment Steven
Seagal his name I don't know how much
money he has he's like a real Republican
right like you like for Trump and [ __ ] I
mean of course he is of course he is who
I mean a guy like that would love a guy
like Trump because Trump is so [ __ ]
you know whatever he is what's that oh
right yeah he does the [ __ ] Putin
[ __ ] dude this is another [ __ ] great
great video it's just a [ __ ] this
this is what I wanted to watch dude this
video is [ __ ] come on this video is
first of all it's called oh my god Wow
oh my god full video okay you know it's
a minute 43 long but this guy first of
all he's responding to does it say it
here does it does all that stuff in here
and we just play it this is stuff
there's a stuff st. Bernard on the table
for no reason I mean this room couldn't
look more yes I cannot believe this room
you have this
they didn't know my money I'd yes'm yeah
she's asking she's telling him that
she's pregnant I don't want languages
pregnant so no is his life as a champion
[Music]
dude guy I don't know what's funnier
that one or the [ __ ] one where the
guy goes okay in the [ __ ] the vine
where he goes okay where the girls
this is so fun
okay so insecure the host didn't secure
the thing ever she goes hi hi okay I
mean he's in a [ __ ] remote jungle has
never seen a cell phone before and she
just is like hi okay is it going to
shoot me oh wow and of course it uses
the strap the [ __ ] backpack with the
strap do you use that you have to use
that I use that I don't [ __ ] around if
you've got the shoulders on the backpack
and you have the strap that does it like
this I use that I use the strap that
comes across the chest do you know why
people like your dork your dorky and I
go like this no I'm not no I'm not you
never know which shoulder is [ __ ]
bigger than the other because I'm
constantly working out those Rocky
Mountains and you don't know if the
[ __ ] thing is gonna fall and I'm a
world traveler bro I travel so much so
when I put the [ __ ] thing on you
don't know if the right straps gonna
come down or the left straps going to
come down because my shoulders
you know the [ __ ] Lord of the Rings
were shot on those [ __ ] so I
clip it and we're good to go
strap it clip it good to go strap it
clip it good to go that was so dope and
I saw that [ __ ] strap in the front of
the backpack was you was was came out I
was like that you know what that changed
the game bro
you know what I thought when the strap
came out and there's someone's like you
could just strap it and I was like oh
you could do that in the front they go
yeah and I went wow I [ __ ] love it
dude okay um so anyway dude do you guys
have New Year's resolutions I don't know
if I do sometimes people are like I
don't believe in I don't believe in it
that I don't say that it's not Santa
news there's one by Shelby Balan my new
year's resolution is to stop wondering
if I'm good enough for other people and
start wondering if they're good enough
for me
legitimately only a girl would say that
that's so weird that that's such a chick
thing to say how many times has I think
probably [ __ ] 75% of women have
thought New Year's you know what
you know it's time to stop doing
wondering if I'm good enough for other
people and start wondering if they're
good enough for me
I cry a lot that's what that means you
cried a lot last year um you know you're
not gonna come January 4th she's gonna
be like does he like me like dude I love
news resolutions cuz they go they they
[ __ ] burn in flames in January 6th you
know here's another one by I'm do we
just [ __ ] I don't know one fire sent
me these my newsletters is is gonna be
to stop going above and beyond for
people who won't do this a for me there
you go there you go there it is and
that's a dude oh now okay there's a
version of a dude that would do that a
guy who works out so much and [ __ ]
has such [ __ ] big muscles let's say
doesn't seem like he has that crazy big
muscles but he has some big muscles wow
dude
oh my god Wow that he said that you're a
guy bro my news resolution my new my new
year's resolution is this is gonna be to
stop going above and beyond for people
who won't do the same for me wow dude
that is insane to think that just live
life dude if you're if you have to I how
do you do it how do you think that for
real
like also thinking it this is when he
wrote at December 26th like the next few
days he's not gonna be doing that
you know if that's my favorite part he's
like well it's not Jerry first
technically so I'll paint the guy's
house here's another one here's another
one let's go to I like these these are
good this is wow it's really really
really [ __ ] annoying that every time
I clip click on it it goes to the
browser and the browser opens up way too
low and I have to drag it up wow this
one sucks this is the worst one [ __ ] a
New Year's resolution commit to daily
excellence like the guy doesn't [ __ ]
jerk-off and lounge around sometimes
like the guy doesn't [ __ ] think like
I'm gonna kick that guy's ass sometimes
oh and then someone wrote under it this
slaps come on
mm 19's [ __ ] this slaps with [ __ ]
three fire emojis a shut up everyone
commit to daily excellence
dude the phrase daily external
excellence can go can go [ __ ] itself for
real it's just as bad as this slaps well
Luke who let the children out of the
playgrounds committed daily excellence
huh
yeah you think it slaps dish let's see
this one [ __ ] Stoney smoke where roll
a blunt and start your new year's
resolutions early ah got no job that's
weird it's from Stoney smoke we're smoke
we're you know here's another one by
kids go my new year's resolutions stop
doing hardcore kick cocaine and move on
from my divorce keep your heads up
queens your crown will slip oh god I
2020 my huge resolution stop to win by
the way who cost cocaine hardcore
cocaine well look you play the
children's out of the playground Junior
is the solution to stop the hardcore
cocaine and move on from divorce keep
your heads up queens your crown will
slip
I hate sayings dude keep your heads up
Queen your crown will slip let's see
that [ __ ] there's like two replies
they're not good all right let's see
another one
New Year's resolution is to learn how to
spell Massachusetts they're not creative
oh this is Rachel Senate I don't know
who this is but she isn't blue checkmark
new year's resolution tits and ego get
bigger okay some perv rights under it
which one first
some guy rights under it why does every
girl want their tits bigger I just do
not understand well you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] sir dude why does every girl want
their tits th e re why does every girl
want their tits bigger sir ruined the
English language here's another one ah
ah honty from a news resolution I'm
simply resolution I'm simply going to be
hotter that's a good one won't go to the
gym once you know here's another one
news resolutions stay single sir sad
can't get a man obviously you know and
and and now has to act like it's her
idea Wow amazing news resolution stay
single
what is it [ __ ] okay anyway what is
Wow Brenda sharp just texted me
something that was way too long okay
cool cool man thanks for texting me a
[ __ ] paragraph I'll read it later uh
I'm on this thing on New Year's Eve also
on NBC where they talk of a do though
year wrap-up I did it with Brent Morin
it was fun they always asked me [ __ ]
that I've already talked about on my
podcast so I'm always like rip-roaring
to go what the [ __ ] create your account
on Twitter no login thank you very much
login not sign up pissed pissed pissed
pissed already logged in got hit
again [ __ ] yes what do you guys think
about you I'm in that man so many people
watch that show you so many people watch
that show it was really a hard to shoot
the scene the last scene because of how
I was well I don't want to ruin it but
it's a cool [ __ ] ending and but you
should watch you on on on on what do you
call it whatever it is Netflix so many
people watch it and I had a good time
doing it and also I did fun people are
saying I did a good job and I really
appreciate that thank you very much
your boys an actor dude your boys gonna
yeah your boys an actor oh yeah he gets
on stage oh yeah he does [ __ ] way
more shows than Bryan Callen on stage
two bigger crowds but your boy also is
an actor let's not forget dude I love
doing that kind of [ __ ] but anyway I'm
on this this toast 2019 on NBC and they
put this clip on there right now I
tweeted it can they talk about that I
did not realize how good podcasts could
be until I heard his podcast this is the
thing about Pam as wonderful as Keith's
voice is on television places to hide a
body it was even better on a podcast Wow
and there was one time where he said Pam
and it had like three syllables in it
was the time of day playing man this
guy's the goat at talking I looked at in
that I'm white so but yeah so they put
me on there which is cool and it's
hilarious that they put my [ __ ]
podcasts on NBC which is ridiculous
that's so funny I'm 10,000 followers
away from 1 million followers
1 million followers on Twitter that's
cool you know tell people to follow me I
guess so I can get that who cares dude
jared leto whoa what what the
dude he posted on Twitter Merry
Christmas and Happy Holidays with a
Santa hat on and no shirt and it's like
essa sexy
what what are you doing bro hey you won
an Oscar hey what you doing I don't know
if I think you won an Oscar so [ __ ]
what you're doing is the [ __ ] or you
want an Oscar so what are you doing
because you want an Oscar
it's so weird he's doing he did that
then lack of humility from people is
just wow
and then I wrote you want an Oscar lmao
what's going on okay but yeah he's a
good actor anyway dude that's what's up
for for today happy new year everyone
and if you're in Chicago come see me
tomorrow night ring in then bring in the
new year
you guys I'm having a good time in in
Chicago where's the ending one this one
fell here
so download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market you can
text me still and I text back I tried to
text back man you guys are so many but
there's [ __ ] over 70,000 people
texting me but eight one eight two three
nine seventy eighty seven and you can
support by buying merch at the merch
store crystalline crystal calm
oh and we're restocking the life rip so
d do we made a double order and they
sold out even quicker I don't know
what's going on people you guys loved
those hoodies which is great but Puri
Illinois Chicago Illinois Orillia
Ontario for some reason Irvine Pasadena
West Palm Beach
Robinson Mississippi Rohnert Park
California where is it in Las Vegas
Nevada all crit Christa all acoustic
calm getting it get your tickets on
there and you can go do that and they
make great gifts or whatever but you
guys are [ __ ] great thanks for
listening and job interviews over my
friend see you guys
[Music]